here we think you'll be talking about  today congresswoman Katie Hill is  stepping down amid allegations of  improper relationships with staff  members the freshman Democrat has  acknowledged and apologized for an  inappropriate relationship with a  campaign staff member but she has denied  allegations of a romantic relationship  with a congressional aide last week  explicit leaked photos of Hill were  published online she blamed a smear  campaign by her estranged husband Hill  said in a statement quote having private  photos of personal moments weaponized  against me has been an appalling  invasion of my privacy it's also illegal  and we are currently pursuing all of our  available legal options all this awkward  always difficult you say well I did do  that but I didn't do that much to see  how it ends up